hi I'm Jane Fonda I'm Lily Tomlin and
we're doing an auto complete complete
interview for wired people really wanted
to know things we don't know what we're
saying
what is Jane Fonda's workout it's an
exercise program for very elderly people
I didn't realize it was semi
pornographic actually when I look at it
now I get embarrassed I mean the thing I
could show you know stuff that I'm doing
that I'm ashamed of and you did pro
Terrell really worked it's remains the
top-selling home video of all time right
even more than yours you think you had
any has any bearing on the fact that you
had two hip replacements actually three
I'm okay next let's see what was Jane
Fonda's first movie taal sorry memory
with tony Perkins yeah directed by Josh
lope and the problem was that both Josh
and I were in love with Tony Perkins so
it became a problem really yes what
college did Jane Fonda drop out of I
dropped out of Vassar
so there Vassar I could go to I could go
back and like at each band I would be a
popular oh he's good you can always go
back I could teach so many different
things what does Jane Fonda eat for
breakfast
my boyfriend well toasted buttered on
both sides she doesn't have a boyfriend
shush I can fantasizing okay we better
move on that's what color or Jane
Fonda's eyes they're blue they're blue
like my father wisdoms pools of wisdom
right what does Jane Fonda beauty
secrets good genes on a lot of money oh
God can you hold one minute hold on
we're gonna be so boring like where does
lowly shop
what is Lily Tomlin real name
Jane Fonda's my real name I had to
change it
my real name is Mary Jean Tomlin what
did Lily Tomlin say to Obama your fly's
open and I say I voted for you no
because you walked over there and
whispered in his ear when you were
getting the Kennedy honor and everyone
saw her she could see the questions
coming up on the video prompter for him
and she could see what was coming and
you went over and whispered in his ear
yes I did
I saved Wilder that time I can only I
can only get in the same room with Trump
what year was Lily Tomlin born 1974 you
skipped this what is Lily Tomlin doing
over as much she's working at Denny's I
of a night shift
del Taco the one on you Brea what is
Lily Tomlin famous for her chocolate
chip cookies they might but they want to
know the truth the truth
how old was Jane Fonda and Barbarella
I was actually 31 years old and pregnant
with my first child
my husband was directing the movie how
did Jane Fonda get famous wouldn't you
like to know
yes Jane I was the daughter of Henry
Fonda that's how I got famous for Grace
and Frankie how much will be paid do we
sit I don't think we know they tell us
we're gonna get paid sort of and then
they but they put it in a bunch of like
mumbo jumbo and then I call Jane I say
so
how much can you figure out how much
we're getting paid and she only
understood the algorithms yeah I would
be a big help if we only did that's the
trick okay how old was Jane Fonda in 9
to 5 you're 74 worth it no I think I was
about 48 how old were you went year with
it 80 no it was seven yeah I was about
41 so you were about 42 and a half or
something see she's a year and eight
months younger
me here lil who did Lily Tomlin marry I
married Julio Iglesias but it was
difficult because I didn't speak Spanish
our Lily Tomlin and Jane Fonda grade
eight are we friends of course we're
friends yeah did Lily Tomlin win an Emmy
so many how many just numerous numerous
Emmys yes oh let me just reflect back on
the passing years were you nominated for
the one that Donna and I played two
hobos with you oh yeah I love that
special the Vegas special yeah who did
Lily Tomlin play on laughing I play so
many things so many different characters
are so many people I played on living
inside of a clayey hobo hobo named Wanda
Fonda which I later was able to imbue on
her persona and Ernestine I played
Ernestine that's true and was Lily
Tomlin in steel magnolias I was I played
dizzy or whatever her name was
[Music]
Ouisa that's right wheeze I play Ouisa
and then they had to reshoot the whole
thing with Shirley MacLaine it was very
costly and it set me back quite a pretty
penny give me that okay can Jane Fonda
speak French
oh absolutely mulku hi mom where's your
pal come in with a española that's all
you ever hear can Jane Fonda sing can I
sing oh you can my real god they could
have had a singing career no I just
tried no you did I mean I can carry a
tune okay she's a singer guys can I wire
Jane Fonda can I write can I write Jane
Fonda can I write yes I have a blog Jane
Fonda calm and I answer my letters and I
really care about she never even goes to
sleep until she's answered all her
emails yeah those are emails but this is
even bad blog my check out my blog is
really good so yes you can write me on
my blog oh it's not the bean
coming up I was nervous who has Jane
founder been married to is that what it
says yeah whoa let's see Roger Vadim the
French director who directed Barbarella
Tom Hayden one of the great movement
activists builders of social movements
they legislated her mind great political
mind and I miss him they both passed and
then Ted Turner he's still around
creator of CNN and big buffalo burgers
and things like yes yes Ted's Montana
grill and he's he's really great
when is Jane Fonda gonna shut up this
birthday December 21st I'm winter
solstice just turned 81 it's the
shortest day of the year they work real
hard that's so fast it to be torn anyone
quickly that way does Jane Fonda hunt
yes I know you draw much I have I don't
need more did you eat it then always I
never shot anything I didn't eat okay
here we go how is the Lily Tomlin
related to John Travolta John Travolta
is my illegitimate child
how old is Lily Tomlin and Jane Fonda
what she's I've already said it
everybody older than I am way they
weren't watching the host show how long
was Lily Tomlin on West Wing I was on
West Wing about four years I had a sag
nomination which is saying a lot in
those days now it's not so much of
course we both have sag nominations this
year this is me the other one is Jane
Fonda related to Jane Seymour I am
related to the original Jane Seymour
fourth wife of Henry the fifth thank you
very much yes I am it's just James I'm
related to Tom Brokaw no I wish I was
related to his wife says Jane Fonda in a
relationship yeah with her she's my pal
I have a lot of relationships is Jane
Fonda vegan no some nice animals eats I
do I kill and eat you know
I do Jane Fonda is she John yeah of
course I'm a grandmother I have two
grandchildren my granddaughter who's 15
goes to I shouldn't even say this
publicly they're great smart beautiful
yes they are they're really special this
Jane Fonda grace are freaky
she's Frankie well why don't you watch
the show and find out where was Lily
Tomlin in 1902 where was Lily Tomlin
born Detroit Michigan does Lily Tomlin
have children there's not a no children
who is a comas brother my brother is
Richard Tomlin and he's funny
is Lily Tomlin is hair real come over to
my place you indicator grab of it and
you can see but my characters hair is
well that's the real hair my hair is
fake but Frankie's hair is real how to
contact Lily Tomlin I'm not as a
forthcoming with a blog as Miss Fonda is
Yeah right Jane and she'll pass it on to
me I've got like eight thousand five
starters blogging because I thought you
were a blogger and I wanted always she
always attributed all that hip stuff she
thought like the highway because I'm
more like a Ramones t-shirt she thought
oh I've got to follow in her footsteps
and she didn't know that like my friend
gave me the Ramones t-shirt I didn't
know who the Ramones were who are they
if you want to mess with her head just
wear different logos and things like
that that'll put her on the wrong path
I'm Jane Fonda Lily Tomlin and this is
the end of our complete auto wired
interview